hey I'm Jesse here at the Wolfram tech
conference 2017 and I'm just talking
with developers and interesting people
who are using our technology and really
kind of innovative ways and I'm here
with shadi who's gonna tell us a little
bit about what she does here at the
company and she has some cool stuff in
Cheverus hi Jesse
so I I'm basically shot yesterday I'm
the manager of image signal processing
here at will from over the past year
it's exciting to see that we are
developing even even at a faster pace
compared to ten years ago when we first
started image processing now we are a
total of more than 350 functions from
just the image and signal processing
capabilities I'm excited to show
everyone the new additions and see their
use from our users okay so what are some
of the I guess biggest improvements from
11.2 that are gonna be in the upcoming
eleven point basically one of the
biggest advancements that we are seeing
now in the image and signal processing
is the use of neural networks and
machine learning a lot of Moore's a lot
of smarter higher level functions that
user can actually just say can don't
worry about the underlying algorithm see
the result right away I would I would
say that's probably the number one big
advance advancement that we have had
within the Wolfram language we are also
trying to be a bit more applied so we
are one at the time looking at the
different verticals including
photography microscopy astronomy
anywhere in different domains of
research and application that people may
be dealing with some images or audio
signals or other types of signals and
trying to see what are the needs that
they have from a software like the
Wolfram language and then trying to fill
in the holes
add more capabilities integrated with
the rest of the system I make sure all
of the workflows that they have is
basically complete and easy to
accomplish that they can solve their
problems in a shorter amount of time so
I think it is very important for us to
do look at these applications and try to
solve it for ourselves as well just to
make sure the workflows are efficient
wolfram language is a very huge
programming language high-level so it's
important for us not to be a little
island doing image and signal processing
only so we are building bridges into
other parts of the language making use
of great capabilities of symbolic and
numeric calculations that we have in the
system as well as geometric regions time
series so we're trying to be the more
modern structures like data sets for
instance and trying to really leverage
all of that it's gonna it's kind of
really bringing a much easier experience
to the user at the end if the whole
system is well integrated whenever we do
find inconsistencies we try to fix it
whenever we design new functions we try
to make it consistent with the rest of
this is with the rest of the system so
that the user doesn't have to keep
remember the special cases for different
functions so consistency I think is one
of the big aspects I've been looking
into it very specifically for especially
like image audio you know at at least
that domain and then the rest of the
system and my talk later today is
actually gonna be details of it let's
not get into the details and as I said
feature complete and the last one I have
here is better documented we can't
attach ourselves to the system and go
out and talk about what they produce the
documentation of the Wolfram language
which is already great is I think the
number one source for everyone to get
started and with the language and get
started in new areas of the language so
we are really putting a lot of effort
into adding examples to our
documentation application section is one
of the best places to go oh I use that
all the time whenever I don't know how
to use a function paper yes but then
things like options possibility choose
how this function relates to other
functions so we are
putting some very dedicated care into
updating our documentation making it
more intuitive and usable for our users
so I don't know much about neural nets I
only ever see it in the domain of data
science I've never like seen it used and
image processing so what exactly our
neural nets used for it in this area
you've probably seen image identify
right I have I don't know how it works
but yes so the idea of neural networks
is basically and then it's not a new
concept it's an older concept the reason
why it's brought up again in this era is
that because the power of the computers
is greater than what it was three
decades ago so computers can handle big
data and can handle neural networks with
a whole lot more layers the additional
layers is actually gonna give capability
for the users not to actually pre
process their data in our case images or
audio and just has kind of the raw data
just the image into the neural network
and have the network learn the features
that is going to be useful for any task
like classification and things like that
image identify in our system was the
first function that used in your life
growth framework that's introduced in
the language all it does is in this
example it says identify what are the
objects and they imagine and this is
it's an apple bread delicious second
function that we are trying to work on
is to see it is to be able to find
individual objects or different objects
in an image this image contents is now
giving us a data segment bounding boxes
and oh that's cool class you know
dimension is basically extracted from
bounding box the little sub image of it
and even the probability so how
confident we are that's like that's a
big Where's Waldo
[Music]
it is Where's Waldo you know have you
tested it on a Where's Waldo image no in
fact this is this is not even documented
yet and 1100 tree but we are talking
about it it's coming it's this one this
instance is just trained on the bought a
hundred classes of objects so it doesn't
understand everything in the world in a
Waldo but it is gonna be trained on
sophisticated dataset and eventually you
know just just be able to explain what
is in the image what is this image it's
a you know in this case we can say it's
a dining table with so many fruits on it
right yeah so already from the classes
of objects that you detect from the
image you can explain what's happening
in the image which is which is kind of
science fiction that kids they go right
nobody guessed we would actually could
do things like that but there is more
than image classification or object
classification in the image things like
restyling which is being I think them
with a lot of this conference it's a
very fun yeah it's a very fun function
so you can this one is basically takes
then neural network is basically getting
two big inputs the input image and the
style image and then passes this through
the network trying to find similar
regions in the input image in their
style image to the local regions of the
input image and restyle it so that it
makes you actually eventually look like
this style image so in this case we're
just styling that same image the fruits
to just the painting of a winter season
well I don't know how to do any art so I
can be an instant artist with this there
you go and then this is for instance
another application example you're
looking at an image and trying to guess
whether you know what's the depth for
every pixel in the image so here we are
using that model which is as well a new
function in the system a bunch of
pre-trained a lot of pre trained
networks a lot more is going to be added
not only by us internally but we're
opening it up for submission to external
people as well so for instance this
network was trained on a bunch of images
and then ground truth known depth for
the images
and then given that knowledge now
passing it a new image it can actually
understand or guess estimate what's the
depth for each individual pixel in the
image and then we can put this in a kind
of a 3d plot to show what's the depth
for each pixel of the image well
correctly the pair actually shows out
being a bit closer
this reminds me hey what's up we're
doing a Facebook live session so great
[Laughter]
that was meant to actually was actually
converted this our APIs he is his
converted a lot of these pre-trained
network networks into our system in fact
working primarily on this net model
function and the network repository
that's gonna be released hopefully very
soon cool so it sounds like there's a
lot of like new incredible features that
are gonna be in the upcoming 11.3 build
can you tell me a little bit I I looked
at your your talk a little bit before
this can you tell me a little bit about
the speech recognition stuff that you're
hoping to to roll out eventually well
let me start with audio in general only
was introduced last year in version 11
already I think it was great one of the
best aspects of our audio objects and
Mathematica is that it can handle old in
for another four version of an audio
object so you can bring all of the data
into the memory for faster processing
but if your data is larger if you have a
whole bunch of even smaller signal audio
files but very so many of them you
practically cannot bring all of that
data into the memory
you can interact with all of those files
as an in-and-out of poor fashion so
you're just linking to the file reading
streaming data from the files into the
system processing and using it and then
putting it backward or discarding it
basically okay this is one of the great
aspects now where are we going with
audio already in version 11 we had a
whole bunch of filtering and processing
and analysis and extracting features
like was the loudness of the whole new
object and whether the spectral features
of the audio where is the frequency and
where is the fundamental for the main
frequency burn what are the format's of
this audio object which is one of the
fundamental things that people will need
in speech and so forth however as we are
going smarter and more higher-level
obviously people do not want to learn
necessarily everything about
fundamentals of speech analysis so we
thought it would be more on target if
you start doing things like direct
speech recognition for instance or
speech synthesis which is one of the
things for any conversational system
that you would like to do and basically
you need speech recognition then some
text analysis to do you know in the
background understand what the what the
spoken audio was and then try to either
come up with an answer or infer some
knowledge from it and then give an
answer or continue the conversation
using speech synthesis system so speech
synthesized was the first function and
well after all of those lower-level
all your measurements towards speech we
introduced speech synthesized and still
as an experimental feature I think in
11:1
but we're moving on with neural network
capabilities for doing more
sophisticated analysis of the signals
and specifically towards speech we're
gonna be doing based on the feature as
we get back from speech signal we will
be able to do resynthesis as well which
is kind of a more effect like signal to
speech signal processing so if I want to
make myself look like Minnie Mouse I can
probably do that with the upcoming
speech resynthesis function and man
speech recognizes I think that still not
completely resolved still under active
research development as well we're going
to be putting a whole lot of emphasis on
that as well for in our upcoming
versions the the reason why we haven't
done a whole lot of it is that the
research on specifically neural network
on audio is just advancing as we speak
as well and then on the other hand the
neural network capabilities within the
Wolfram language was slightly behind
handling audio so the very low-level
features and needs that we have for
doing audio processing using neural
networks is just being built up as we
speak
okay yeah so so I think there is going
to be a whole lot of opportunities ahead
of us now that we have a start on it but
I think speech basically is going to be
the very first application domain of all
your processing that that's so cool well
thanks for talking with me shadi I
really appreciate you and talking to the
viewers here too so thanks again if you
have questions please leave them in the
comments we can't get to them here but
definitely go on community Wolfram comm
see if someone has your question and we
might be able to get to the questions
you leave in the comments later you can
also private message the Wolfram ikaw
Thanks